the jogan experience I got a good story
for you we got a story it's very funny
so I was at not Dame or Notre Dame Navy
this last week in Dublin you Hunchback
yeah I am a [__] Hunchback that's why
it worked you just got back from England
from Ireland yeah wow and uh anyway the
first night we're down there we did a
show Thursday they we're down there my I
brought my Father which was very funny
to see all right so this guy comes down
Phil's down there we go to this bar with
Brady Quinn he's one of the notame
alltime Legends J Mo knows him I know
him J Mo know qu he's dou Ohio boy oh
yeah let's go hell yeah but [__] guy
we're at this bar we're drinking after
the show this [__] Irish kid shows
up he is Conor McGregor Skin Tight Pants
[__] button down no offense to him
coked out of his mind you've never seen
someone this high in your life
like so he swipes we're sitting there
drinking he swipes all the beers off the
corner of the bar reaches over Brady
Quinn's shoulder and he to me he's like
big [__] fan man and I was like oh
thanks man and Bray Quinn just gave one
of these like [__] who the [__]
this guy damn this guy's crazy yeah and
when he did that he bumped him a little
and the guy immediately was like you
don't [__] bump me he started [__]
doing his whole UFC thing so he's
spazzing we all have to break it up we
have to break up this fight for 20
[__] minutes I turn around my father
is back there
going his turn around ready go [__] are
you GNA do all right Phil Phil tried to
fight him too Phil if Phil would have
died defending Brady Quinn in Dublin OH
I'd be a hero Vikings death that is how
my dad should go totally I mean that's
Legend anyway so we break this fight up
the guy's a fan he's like yeah let's do
a [__] Jagger bomb let's have a f
let's take it easy man [__] I was
like all right I'll do it we [__] we
get [__] phazed this guy's on a Coke
rant for like 15 minutes of just
straight like [__] but Quinn so you
can damn Quin Ru qu he's the man so
anyway he's a handsome dude this guy's
full UFC he's genuinely an MMA guy he
trains with McGregor yeah oh really
allegedly he was on cocaine he might
have been fabricating sure it's Patty
pimble but you know how these guys go he
just shadow boxes the whole time you're
talking to him and he's like yeah
[__] body shot body shot Li liver
straight to your [__] face back out
this guy sounds like a nightmare hell
and you can't you can't move you can't
Flinch to the body cuz then you'll
literally get punched in the [__]
yeah and then we're like oh we're going
to get killed and he's like ah you're a
[__] NZ guy aren't you and I was like
no way that's what this is about this
guy's going to beat my ass in Dublin for
being a Nate Diaz guy right anyway the
the whole night the guy leaves
everything's okay the next night get
done with the shows
Brady's in the green room we're all
hanging out we're having a good time
that [__] Irish guy just walks
straight into the Green Room what what
of the theater yeah what and Bray Quinn
looks at me like what the why would you
invite this guy I like I did not invite
this [__] guy he walks in he's
like [__] crazy [__] I was like
dude this is the whole time he's just
he's still Shadow Boxing still bothering
everybody in a good way though this time
at this point it's fun yeah he's
bothering everybody we start walking we
start going to a bar he's like we go to
this [__] bar I'm like dude all the
bars in Dublin Clos at midnight yeah
he's like nah this is D this isn't
[__] gay New York the bar stay open
every bar we go to is
closed like dude Dublin sucks New York
rules he's like you know we don't have
in Dublin [__]
pronouns the next three people that walk
by us are gay interracial couples
holding hands like dou
gay we finally get to a bar this guy by
the whole time all he's been doing is
trying to fight everybody we get to a
bar we start to get to this bar and he
kind of is like a let's go to that bar
you're a [__] Legend at that bar
let's go to that one not this one I'm
like let's go we're going to this one so
we go into the bar as soon as we start
walking in a
bouncer a just a bald fat bouncer walks
out and is like
you just beats the [__] out of the Irish
guy
this whole time he's been like I [__]
knock out anybody no problem why did he
throw him a regular but he must have had
a problem in this he the whole time he
was like let's go to another bar the
second we get to this bar five bouncers
swarm just St wh That's he didn't want
you to go to he's like no no we're good
here now this is how cool this [__]
guy was he gets his ass beat he's bloody
split open he gets out of all five of
them runs down the alley and then turns
and looks at all of them and goes
he squares up and runs off again it was
like damn that guy
ruled Jesus he probably does that every
weekend it's a hell of a drug anyway
that was the best guy I've ever met
hilarious in Du he like [__] run
Dublin man we
fucku you do vior Street yeah what yeah
Vicor Street [__] rules great the
Irish crowd is like they're [__]
they yell out the whole time having time
though they're [__] funny they're
funny people
I had my beer on a [__] speaker and
it fell off and they go
nuts all you have to do is hit a [__]
up the ra anytime they're giving you an
Applause break go up the ra what's that
mean up the IRA
[Music]
oh wow you're getting political in
another country up the up the r Dublin's
fun